Chris and Phil oh why did you want to
make this movie
we love Miles Morales we thought that
was an amazing way to tell the
spider-man story we fell in love with
the book and when Sony came to us and
said you know we want to do an animated
spider-man movie we said we'll do it but
it has to be miles and and we started
yeah give it up for Miles Morales and to
think and then we got sort of carried
away and and it kind of grew from there
the whole idea is how do we tell this
story in a refreshing way how do we tell
it through somebody else's experience
and how do we put a new spin on it and
and miles is a great start this is the
best opportunity ever to tell a story
that actually looked like a comic book
like you were literally walking into a
comic book so from the very beginning we
said what can we do how can we make a
movie that looks like nothing you've
ever seen before that's like a
completely unique cinematic experience
that that feels like you're walking into
the pages of a three-dimensional comic
book and to everybody here its credit
the these three geniuses over here they
were able to make it look like something
you've never seen before and something
has to be seen on a big screen we've
been fans of shamekh for a long time we
loved him ever since we something for
the first time at dope and he's we've
known him for a while from different
auditions and things that we've always
felt like this guy is brilliant he's so
sincere he's funny he's cool he's
everything that Myles is he's got a
really unique like positive take on life
his first comic-con is his first time
he's been here yeah and from the from
the beginning we're like this guy is is
the guy and and and we were right I was
thankful for the opportunity the fact
that it looks this beautiful and the
fact that the writing is so amazing and
that the cast is so amazing was a
pleasant surprise but the fact that I
was able to have the opportunity to
audition to
book and become Miles Morales was the
original oh my gosh this would be
amazing well Jake why don't you tell us
a little bit about your Peter Parker
well it's well it's Peter Parker at 40
and it's Peter Parker with a bad back
and it's Peter Parker who's not sure if
he still wants to be spider-man and what
it means to be you know what it means to
be spider-man after the excitement of
being spider-man he meets miles in this
movie and miles needs him to be a mentor
and needs things from him but he doesn't
see himself as a mentor or a teacher and
he doesn't want to be but he sees
something really special in this guy and
it reminds him of what he loves about
having those powers miles just needs to
teach you he doesn't really want to be
spider-man he doesn't want this extra
responsibility you know he's just trying
to go to school like a normal kid middle
school all of a sudden he bit by this
spider and he got these powers and now
people trying to kill him
and he has these Duty of saving multiple
universes and now I meet this Spider Man
and I'm like hey dude you need to teach
me no I don't need to teach you why not
go away kid dude I really need you to
help me save the world
not now and I think Peter is and seen
just not now not now on your own time Oh
miles
and I think Peters in a situation where
he sees this kid asking something from
him and he doesn't want to give it to
him but he's so persistent
and anytime someone's really persistent
after a while if you're any sort of a
human you break down and give in Haley
let's go to talking about Gwen Stacy aka
spider Gwen whoo
what excited you most to play her the
fact that she is really just the
toughest and the coolest and the
smartest and the most capable one in the
room and she knows it all of these
characters are born out of tragedy on
some level and the thing that's
interesting about intersecting their
stories is for the first time there's
somebody out there that that knows what
they're going through
and the thing that's so interesting to
me about the relationship between you
know spider-gwen and miles and and in
our movie all of these guys is that they
finally have like a tribe that they can
hang out with and here's somebody who
like doesn't have a real buddy and is
almost afraid to have a friend okay
right you know and I mean and so the
fact that like they kind of get to find
each other is a really like beautiful
part of the movie well as far as style
you know a lot of it you know it starts
with with Phil and Chris you know and
this this whole approach to the movie
which is that we're trying to to push
every aspect of this in a way that you
haven't seen before you know and we're
being challenged every day to think of
ways to to tell this story in a way that
that you haven't seen before and then as
far as you know the character is it
really starts with the book you know
like the book the heart of the book is
is Myles and his family and their
relationship and and that's that's the
heart of the movie it's a really
ambitious movie it's probably the most
ambitious thing about it is that it
introduces a whole new version of
spider-man
I mean comics fans and you know most of
you guys you've known miles for a while
but the the world at large doesn't
really know him and doesn't really
doesn't really have experience of a
different character kind of bearing this
mantle and the fascinating thing about
it to me is that you know the same
things that applied to Peter Parker with
great power comes great responsibility
those same ideas transfer on to another
character who couldn't be more different
than Peter in so many ways and yet the
strength of the original idea of the
character still holds firm it's still
spider-man what we're really trying to
achieve too was just a
an interpretation of a comic book that
actually made it on screen and felt
cinematic but still was was beholden to
the original source material which was a
comic where did you get the inspiration
for this new approach I've literally
torn from the pages of the comics I mean
100% and and and then it was just a
matter of looking at you know the the
process that we go through to make these
movies and and see how visually you
could you could translate that that flat
medium into a three-dimensional space
and project it and and still feel you
know the scope of a large film but also
the intimacy of the page and and the
panel on the page one of the greatest
strengths of comics is that it manages
to encapsulate in one image a really
succinct powerful story point or motion
or action and in in in our process of
animation we really tried to achieve
that same feeling mile story takes place
in an alternate dimension to our own the
spider versus basically you know all of
these alternate ways of telling this
story and all of these different people
that experience it and and the thought
of this movie was what if those
different stories intersected and what
would it do how would it shake them up
what would happen if these people met
and I think that's like the power of
this character is that we told his story
so many different ways and and like she
makes says anyone could be behind that
math and we can all imagine ourselves
behind that mask I think that's the cool
thing about spider-man and it's the
interesting thing about comics culture
and the fact that there's so many of
these movies that the story keeps
getting told and each time the that's
the differences in variations in the
ways that it gets told those are really
interesting to us well it looks
absolutely amazing thank you guys so
much for sharing that with us here at
comic-con big round of applause for our
panelists
thank you guys so much so looking
forward to this
you